jetzt die lang war eines sicher der
titel als exportweltmeister der gehörte
deutschland doch das blatt das hat sich
gewendet im mai ist die handelsbilanz
erstmals seit 30 jahren ins minus
gerutscht das heißt deutschland hat mehr
güter importiert als ins ausland
exportiert deutsche autos gelten im
ausland immer als verkaufsschlager
firmen wie daimler thyssenkrupp oder
siemens haben generationen wohlstand
geschenkt und die welt beeindruckt aber
jetzt jetzt hat sich der marktwert der
deutschen börsenkonzerne halbiert mangel
an arbeitskräften günstiger energie
innovationen und kapital sind daran
schuld und wie genau sich der markt wird
der deutschen unternehmen verringert hat
das zeigen wir im jetzt anhand dieser
grafik zeigt den niedergang zeigt sich
besonders krass hier die deutschen
börsen konzerne die befinden sich wie
sie sehen im sinkflug der marktwert hat
sich im vergleich zur weltweiten
konkurrenz immer weiter verringert das
deutsche unternehmen sind nicht mehr so
viel wert wie früher nur noch ein
deutsches unternehmen der
industriekonzern linde ist unter den
globalen top 100 und selbst blinde hat
seinen firmensitz inzwischen nach dublin
in irland verlegt er mit schuld für den
katastrophalen wirtschaftlichen zustand
deutschlands ist die immer teurer
werdende energie die auch den
unternehmen fehlt um immer weiter
existieren zu können unter experten
wächst die sorge dass deutschland im
winter in eine gigantische gaskrise
läuft bayerns ministerpräsident markus
söder spricht bereits von voll
rationierungen von gas warnt also vor
einer drohenden gas triade bedeutet im
notfall muss die regierung darüber
entscheiden wer das wenige verfügbare
gas bekommt das wirtschaftsministerium
von robert habeck erklärt dass die lage
ernst sei abhilfe schaffen soll hab
ich's plan flüssiggas per schiff nach
deutschland zu holen doch jetzt jetzt
gerät auch dieser plan ins wanken
hauptgrund dafür fehlende
transportschiffe aber wie er wie könnte
dann eine lösung für steigende
energiepreise aussehen alexander
dobrindt vorsitzender der
csu-landesgruppe im deutschen bundestag
und früherer verkehrsminister der
fordert dass hier wir brauchen dringend
einen festen bürger basispreis beim
gases wirksamen schutzschirm gegen die
weitere preise explosion sagt er ohne
ein bürger basisplan werden viele
menschen in deutschland in den nächsten
monaten die steigenden gaspreise nicht
mehr bezahlen können der bürger
basispreis muss befristet ein grund
bedarf an gas für die privaten haushalte
im preis deckeln